jean marc bonjour alors pour la première
fois les start up de la french tech ont
levé moins d'argent sur le dernier
semestre que l'année dernière alors que
tout le monde s'attendait à ce qu'elle
résistait ce que ce phénomène a brisé
l'élan d'un secteur sur lequel on compte
beaucoup pour entraîner la reprise c'est
vrai que c'est un secteur très important
parce qu'il peut servir de locomotive à
la reprise d'un secteur qui crée
beaucoup d'emplois qui crée beaucoup de
valeur et qui préserve la solidité de
l'économie française notamment sur les
marchés internationaux mais c'est vrai
aussi que les startups ont attiré moins
de capitaux que l'année dernière à la
même époque alors qu'elles en ont besoin
2 milliards 7 2 2 milliards 700 millions
c'est un peu moins que l'année dernière
certaines bochum tirer la langue
pour financer leurs investissements ça
signifie quoi ça signifie que le coc
vite qui a complètement abattu le
secteur automobile qui a décimé
l'aéronautique le transport aérien et
surtout le tourisme
et bien c'est aussi attaqué à la french
tech qui pourtant semblait tenir le coup
or on pensait que la french lac était
inattaquable est alors bien sûr c'est
pas catastrophique
la croissance de ce secteur s'est
ralentie et ces entreprises ne pourront
pas comment l'espérer sans doute joué
deux locomotives ou alors il va sans
doute falloir faire quelque chose pour
les aider est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir aider les entreprises digital
comme les autres secteurs la
construction automobile aéronautique ou
encore le tourisme
oui il va falloir il va falloir
surveiller il va pas aller surveiller
parce qu'on en a besoin je vous le
disais pour créer des emplois mais aussi
pour assurer l'indépendance digital de
la france et de l'europe on a beaucoup
parlé d'indépendance de la france envers
les produits pharmaceutiques envers les
masques envers une tests etc
mais on a besoin au site de préserver
notre indépendance par rapport aux
composants électroniques par rapport à
toute cette technologie digitale on n'a
pas sur ce marché les gaffes à comme des
amazones les google il faut donc pousser
nos propres sociétés nos propres licorne
comme on dit ou du moins celles qui
veulent devenir
qui peuvent devient des licornes
notamment dans le domaine de l'internet
des objets connectés
on a un problème avec la 5g évident on a
un problème avec les géo localisation et
là on a énormément en besoin alors oui
on va leur apporter des financements
si le marché lui même ne le permet pas
or le marché est en train de
s'essouffler puisque on le voit on vient
de le voir dans les statistiques
est ce que la france a globalement les
moyens de financer l'ensemble des
besoins de l'économie
alors ça c'est une question récurrente
qui en cas de toulouse qui accueille
tout le monde mais j'ai peut-être vous
surprend il n'y a pas de risques
financiers
à très court terme alors on a
l'impression de distribuer les milliards
tous les jours et d'emprunter mais il
serait trop technique je voudrais
simplement précisé que l'aide aux
entreprises est apportée par des prêts
qui sont garantis par l'état certes mais
ce sont des prêts des prêts qui sont
distribués par des banques et qu'il
faudra rembourser et qui seront
remboursés au total à peu près 140
milliards de prêts ont déjà été
distribués aux entreprises depuis le
début de la crise mais il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui sur ces 140 milliards
vous en avez que 120 milliards vous en
avez 120 me dire qu'ils n'ont pas été
utilisés ça veut dire que les autres
reprises les zones mandé elle désolée
mandé par précaution mais elles pourront
donc les rembourser puisqu'une maison ou
alors les investir y compris dans le
digital dont on vient de parler
autre exemple très simple le côté les
consommateurs les salariés
on sait qu'ils ont constituée d épargne
importante pendant toute cette période
d'avoir va se dire pas eu nos
consommations il ya eu très peu de
consommation et puis ensuite parce
qu'ils ont continué de toucher du
pouvoir de dépenser les allocations des
prestations l'allocation chômage partiel
tout ça à représenter des sommes
colossales
au total cet argent a été principalement
stockés dans les banques sous forme
d'épargné 80 milliards départ d'auch le
problème à court terme
ça n'est pas de trouver de l'argent le
problème c'est de décider les français à
consommer et de décider les entreprises
à investir
le problème c'est que les entreprises et
les consommateurs sont un peu bloquée
donc le consommateur ne consomme pas ou
assez peu il est peut-être en train de
le faire notamment dans les concessions
automobiles et le chef d'entreprise 8
n'avaient ce type à c'est si tous ses
agents la économique
finalement son paradis et ceux qui n'ont
pas confiance et du coup pas la machine
économique n'aura du mal
redémarrer on a certes des problèmes
techniques on aura sans doute des
problèmes à moyen terme de financement
de l'endettement au niveau budgétaire
mais on a surtout pour la rentrée à
rétablir la confiance et ça c'est un
problème politique
c'est leur jeu c'est le défi que doit
relever le gouvernement et sera pas
touati merci beaucoup jean marc
sylvestre d'avoir répondu à des
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialiste économique 1 sur rtl
france